[Music]
okay Adam I'm gonna ask you've dressed
up yeah why have you done this last time
I was on the show I wore a tuxedo yeah
cuz um I wanted to be dressed nicely for
you guys and this time I wanted wear
something fancier than a tuxedo and I
panicked
first of all I started the bar really
high with yes you saw tuxedo is way out
you could shoot the first time I should
have came on the show dressed like I
lived under the Cahuenga underpass event
anything I wore would have been better
yeah but now I look like I'm in the
Solomon Schechter day school production
of the Nutcracker that's exactly what
happened yeah but it looks fantastic
they feel like a butt yeah what's it
called that's called that's called a
Beefeater Beefeater yeah I found that
out today yeah
you'll learn something yeah well I was
like me
and I told Andy I was gonna do this and
he was like don't and I think you were
right well let's talk I tried I you know
is a little more subtle than just don't
yeah you said please yeah it's also
extremely ill-fitting yes I don't know
it's like you know look it's not the
best fit yeah there's all kinds of stuff
yeah and thrashing around doesn't help
it really doesn't help it look like a
Jewish Chris Farley in front of FAO
Schwartz let's talk about your life
Oh real life yeah my real life you have
an eleven month old son I do and your
wife is six three months pregnant
oh okay three months even it's even
weirder yeah three months pregnant but
that means I mean first of all that's
your your you're getting these babies
pretty close together here yeah we
screwed up we screwed up on the first
one and then did not learn from our
mistakes well I think for both of them
to hear it one day Coenen let's be real
these kids are screwed
what happened was we um were playing
fast and loose and
and we got burned with a blessing yeah
so these babies how far apart are these
babies kiddo be 13 and a half month
that's just like well I I have a brother
and a sister we were all like 13 months
apart yeah you're Irish right it is true
it is the group you can mock and no one
cares Jews don't pump them out that
quick we make sure everyone's got a
college fund before we ask so that you
have a debt so this was this was not
planned but it's happened it's happening
we're gonna be very helpful to have
Jewish Irish twins yeah which means that
they will they'll all drink and have
sinus headaches well how does it looks
about your wife how does your wife feel
about being pregnant again so quickly
she's not thrilled yeah it's been two
years of straight pregnancy yeah which
is uh it's kind of a bummer for me
[Laughter]
adjust this belt to where it should be
yeah there you go yeah now it's a trust
that's me yeah this is really this is
actually holding in my gut and then um
it's not great for me because uh she's
bringing it in and and she's like don't
touch me after we have this baby she's
like that's it you know I don't want to
touch you
and it it it's gonna be hard to break it
to you that um like I'm okay with that
after like after two babies you're gonna
regret saying that oh yeah
oh yeah you're gonna be murdered when
you get home no I regretted it here it
is the crowd unless you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna die in a Beefeater
costume that's great no way I'm dressed
for battle oh great